in today's morning rounds why doctors
are urging patients to make eye exams a
priority the American Optometric
Association says 25% of children already
wear or need glasses by the time they
enter kindergarten doctors now recommend
that parents have the eyes of their
school-age children checked every year
dr. tamesha friend pong is a pediatric
ophthalmologist at the Mount Sinai
Hospital in New York good morning doctor
good morning so what can doctors even
detect from babies so young and is it
even true that is it true that babies
can only see black and white when
they're just a few months old right so
when babies are born the visual system
is still immature so they can see light
and call it like red and black and white
and that kind of thing but they're not
going to make out fine details
doctors at birth will check to make sure
the child can at least see light does
the child wince to light that's a crude
assessment of vision and then they'll
look at the eyeball itself make sure
it's structurally normal and look for
the red reflex that dreaded red eye that
we get in our photos that's actually a
good sign that the retina is normal and
everything in the back of the eye is
healthy this happened with my son you
know under the age of 10 a teacher
pointed out what are some of the signs
that we should all be looking for that
child may have trouble seeing sure so
obvious things would be eyes that don't
stay straight eyes that shake eyes that
wander poor fixation poor tracking and
then things as simple as squinting if
your child is constantly squinting when
they're looking at things far away that
could be an indication that they may
need glasses and what impact does it
have on learning it was everything for
me for example when I was in the third
grade I started failing my spelling test
and my teacher alerted my parents you
know you might want to get her vision
checked imagine if that didn't happen I
could have been labeled a bad student
you know not focus not serious and I
didn't even know I had a problem because
the vision I was having at that time was
normal for me and that's when I started
wearing glasses I wish I could have used
that excuse me spelling so at what age
should people take their children get
checked so like I said vision screening
starts at birth and then around one year
going the pediatricians will check
during those well
child visits and then certainly by the
child by the time the child is about
three to five years old they should have
a comprehensive eye exam because there
may be a problem with one eye that's
that you may not be able to detect so
there may be a problem that they need
glasses more on one side than the other
they may have strabismus they may have a
problem in the back of the eye
I just think doctor how many times as a
parent go over a parent-teacher
conference to probably hear their kids
not doing well in a subject and maybe a
lot of times the answer is vision
problems absolutely even things like
misalignments of the eye can impact the
ability to focus and read so those
things do you require comprehensive eye
exam well dr. Tanisha Frimpong thank you
so much thank you - good morning right
as we all get ready to head back to
school some of us already in school yeah
so much thank you too